my dad was a mill my dad was a military
policeman and on my 18th birthday
i told him he's like oh you owe me 300
000 of commissions after i got my trust
fund money and i told him no and he
pinned me down on the ground and took
his 44 magnum and shot it right next to
my right ear and i'm deaf in my right
ear because of that
that's what happened to me on my 18th
birthday
are there any advantages to being deaf
in your right ear no
actually
actually maybe one right now producing
producing like high hat frequency levels
like i can hear what they're supposed to
sound like so i'll plug this ear and i
can hear what they're like kind of like
supposed to be mixed
like so
what like it cuts out the height my
equilibrium gets a little off and i run
into things
you know because yeah because it's gone
and then it makes it and then i'm
already have loss of hearing from fans
and performing you said your your love
album you mixed it yourself i produced
it i wrote it um andrew wepper mixed it
already mastered it
executive produced the project and i
funded it gotcha okay i was gonna say
mixing with only one year would be
[ __ ] hard yeah
yeah i saw we we
put on like a youtube video while we
were driving here
and uh
just kind of randomly it's it showed you
saying you know that but like your dad
fired the gun and you're was it was it
called aaron caught aaron carter being
psychotic for 10 minutes or something no
you watched those videos hell no
it wasn't it was not man
they they say things on you when you're
on live to try to get you to clip you
and they make their 14 28 cents a month
or whatever right right right exactly
exactly like i mean it was definitely
like a hit job video there's no question
about that oh was it oh okay yeah the uh
they showed you saying i'm deaf in my
right ear and then it was like a photo
sequence like
and it was all photos of you talking on
the phone like holding it up to your
right ear like yeah presumably like are
you
so you can kind of hear in your right
ear
i mean
it's like 75 percent gone so
naturally i'm a righty so i do that but
then usually i have to go to speaker
phone
so
i usually talk on speakerphone all the
time so fair enough you know yeah and
dude they're always trying to like
debunk things like
i i
kind of kind of alluded to the fact that
you were coming here right before you
got here right you said that they were
telling you yeah and they were like
you're a liar stephen ain't coming over
there laughing my ass off they and they
and everybody always thinks that they
don't think i own my houses then i show
them my deeds and then they still don't
think i own it they don't think i own
all my four cars and i and i'm like i
show them they don't they still they
it's just it's weird like jealousy type
of things and i mean it's an impossible
thing to be trying to prove it yeah but
like
you know oh here's the deal you kind of
got me that i'm a fire sign so i'm born
since you know on december 7th i'm a
purifier signed double cancer moon and i
will fight you to the [ __ ] death and
i will win i will intellectually destroy
you
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]